Info is one of the best games to play
and it's the right time to play it right
now. My name is Nick. I made $3.3
million in the past two and a half years
selling this exact mechanism.
Let me ask you a question. Imagine you
would have a money printing machine in
your basement without paper feeding into
it. It wouldn't [__] matter how
powerful it is. Nothing would happen.
That's the exact same when you have
content in place like here, but you have
no top of the funnel source that
constantly feeds new eyeballs towards
one specific destination, which is your
profile. And then you walk with that
paper, with that blank paper. You walk
into the coffee shop and you try to pay
and you give that blank paper to the
worker. The worker is probably going to
laugh at you. You need ink. Whether it's
a $5 bill, a $10 bill, even a $100 bill,
the ink gives meaning to the paper for
people to understand the value of it.
And then without heat, ink never sticks
to the paper. Your prospects don't stick
when your offer is weak. When your
marketing, like here, isn't optimized
for massive conversion. Whenever you
don't have a top of the funnel traffic
source coming in, you don't have a
middle of the funnel conversion point.
Then you know what? You give the worker
that bill. You're like, "Cool. Now $5
bill easy for my coffee." But apparently
the worker checks it based on that bank
note detector. And the bank note
detector says there's no [__] water
mark on it. Then the worker thinks
you're a scammer. the worker instantly
thinks you're a scammer because it's a
fake bill. Meaning, if you have no proof
of concept, no tracking, no feedback
loop, no row optimization mechanism that
constantly feeds you with data,
referrals, case studies, or any other
sort of proof of concept. People will
never believe that the whole ecosystem
I'm presenting here could be a potential
solution towards their problem. Think
about that. You need these three
systems. My name is Nick. made $3.3
million in the past two and a half years
selling this exact mechanism towards my
customers. One offer, one funnel, one
price point. Very simple. But it goes a
little bit more in diesel. That's the
reason why I made this video because so
many people on Instagram ask me, Nick,
make a video about this. Now, the first
thing that we need to understand to
start is top of the funnel source. We
need to understand the scripting
process. Imagine this, right? You talk
to a prospect. Very clear. You have your
setter in place. You have your closer in
place. Your whole team is set. Your
payroll is $20,000 a month. Your profit
$100,000 a month. Excellent. But what if
you speak to the wrong person? What
happens is the scripting isn't
optimized. So when the scripting isn't
optimized, you don't speak towards one
specific ICP. Your marketing is too
broad. You attract shitty leads. And
then the problem comes into place where
as you attract the wrong leads. The
closer gets shitty calls. You know what
I mean? You get lowquality sales calls.
What happens is the closer starts to
blame that on the appointment setter
that he is not booking in enough calls.
The setter blames it on the content team
because the content team is not making
the right content for it to deliver the
setter the right quality leads. The
whole team is [__] up because there is
no synergy in this whole component
because of your marketing message. Get
market clarification. ICP conversion is
created the moment the biggest pain the
biggest pain is triggered in the
prospect's mind. So I'm speaking to you
right now. Let me tell you this. This is
$75,000 in cash collected in the last
five days. four days because we still
have a lot of sales calls going on
today. We just took the first one. We
still have six with 80% of the people
being qualified. Now, 80% of this is
profit with a team that can sit at one
dinner table. I have a team that can all
sit at one dinner table with five, six
people operating on high efficiency,
with high profit, with stability in my
business, attracting dream clients. This
is messaging. Right now, for the last
minute, I just described something that
either triggered you or didn't trigger
you. Imagine I would say this in an ad.
You would be like [__] yeah like I want
what this guy has. Meaning relatability
comes into place. We have value based
creatives. We have credibility based
creatives and we have educationalbased
creative. Educationalbased creatives is
educating people about a new solution
that they are unaware about. Credibility
based is leading with proof for them to
clarify that there's proof of concept of
the process that you're showing them.
Valuebased creatives are creatives that
amplify a direct return. like here's the
tracking sheet, here is this sales
training integration, here is this ops
manager blueprint, here is this fitness
protocol for you to become jacked in 30
days. And you have to understand what
this does, right? This is the highest
conversion cycle. It actually creates
conversion in a prospect's mind. This is
the highest trust cycle. People will
trust when you show credibility. And
this is the highest relatability cycle,
meaning people get related. When people
feel related to your situation or they
desire the outcome that you're looking
for, it creates relatability. You want
what I have. I have $75,000 a month in 5
days. I have an amazing team. I work
here with my team. We're here right now
in this house with six people. My ops
manager, my setter, my closer, my
content director, and my filmer. And
that could be part of an outcome that
you're looking for. Lean team, high
profit and efficiency. Psychological
system behind this is conversion,
relatability, and trust. As an example,
valuedriven in-depth reels. You've seen
it on my Instagram. I constantly show
that here. These are all valuedriven
reels. Some are credibility driven, some
are driven from a perspective of
education, and the others are just
purely valuedriven. And I have a perfect
balance between each one of them. Now
when we go back, we have in-depth
YouTube videos. It creates longevity.
And an example of longevity is exactly
this. You're watching right now. If you
would have been interested in what I
have to show, you wouldn't even been
spending your time for the last 8
minutes on watching me. And that's
exactly what YouTube videos do. Like
what you're experiencing right now is
exactly the effect of what a YouTube
video gives. Now there are different
types of YouTube videos. Obviously,
separate YouTube channel with client
testimonials, story sequence scripting.
I was on a mastermind. This was very
funny. I was on a mastermind around two
weeks ago in Dubai and I was speaking on
a stage in front of 25 potential
clients, people that were interested. I
did a launch on my Instagram and 25
people came. Now, the question that I
asked them was, "What is the reason why
you're here?" And all of them said,
"Marketing. I'm here for marketing. I'm
here for sales. No, no, no. I'm here for
fulfillment. I want to know more about
how to build great offers." And I said,
"You're all [__] lying." All of them
were lying because the only reason of
why I got them here without any delivery
or proof of concept that what I do works
is copy. It's copy is the driver that
stimulates marketing. Copy is the driver
the combination of marketing and sales.
Because only based on my verbal copy,
the way I speak, my visual copy, the
things I show, and my in-depth copy
based on words, typing is what got them
there. Nothing else. They don't even
know if my fulfillment is good. They
don't even know anything else. And then
while I was on the mastermind, I really
showcased them the system of how I
constantly solve big pains for my
clients to get people to pay me a lot of
money because the bigger the pain, the
bigger the price, right? For me to be
able to showcase how I solve a solution
that is directly related towards their
problem based on a custom game plan. At
that moment, it made it so easy for me
to upsell 20 to 25% instantly. They were
all sold and they were like, "It makes
so much sense. the things that you're
telling me make sense. And that's
marketing message. Story drop off rate.
It's all fun business. You know what?
Like, it's so [__] fun to make money.
It's so [__] fun to make sales. It's
fun to deliver. When you enjoy and
you're obsessed with your company and
you know you're good at it, it's just
[__] fun. It makes life so much
easier. The problem is you're you're you
have that feeling constantly, right?
You're sitting behind your laptop.
You're doing work, but you feel like
there's something missing. You're
stagnating. You don't know what gets you
to the next level. Like the technical
answer is easy, but the problem is you
don't have clarity on what solves the
problem. You don't know what solves the
problem. You don't know what you need to
do to get to the next level because you
guys are all action takers. We all know.
We're all action takers. It's just that
you're unaware about the problem that
you need to solve for you to scale from
$25,000 a month to six figures a month.
And that's because you don't traction.
If I ask you right now, what is your
cost per acquisition? I guarantee you
don't have an answer on that. If I ask
you right now, what is your cost per
calendar link? Do you understand exactly
how many people drop off whenever you
send an account link in Instagram? No,
you don't. Your setter doesn't track
that. Do you track warm outbound? Do you
track inbound? Do you track cost per
cost per conversion, cost per
acquisition, and cost per show up? No,
you don't. And that's exactly the reason
why you can get to the next level. So,
as we talked about the first foundation,
messaging extremely crucial scripting,
then content optimization done. But the
tracking part is what gives stability in
your company. It makes you it it I
always say like this. It allows you to
go from a freestyler to actually
somebody with proper knowledge. Somebody
that builds a company. Somebody that
builds a team. Somebody that gives their
team peace. You as a man are the one
that needs to provide for your family.
Think about this. You as a man creates
the source of cash flow that comes from
your business.
Meaning, if you don't organize [__] if
you don't plan [__] you don't have a
system that constantly tracks data that
gives feedback and allows you to
optimize your ads, your content, and
your team, you'll never make more money.
You need to know the stats. You need to
know what your tracking system looks
like. You need to understand how you're
putting this tracking in system into
place for you to make money. Let's go to
the next step. Enough talked about this
second technical ecosystem. Like I went
into into the psychology of things, but
how does it actually look like for us to
build an ad campaign? What do we really
need to build a build an ad campaign? We
have two different sources, right?
Because mostly you run a VSSL funnel.
The VSSL funnel is outdated. It doesn't
[__] work anymore. So why would you
utilize it right now in the market when
we all know that content is the core? We
can just run traffic towards content for
it to be able to create conversion with
a lean team and high profit. An info
business isn't made to have 17,000
employees for you to be able to sell it
in the future. An info, this is what I
heard so many times. I make $300,000 a
month. The main thing that we do with
info is create as much capital and cash
flow as possible for us to allocate that
towards different sources. Now,
technical ecosystem, a lot of you guys
probably run a VSSL funnel or you run no
ads. That's even a bigger problem. You
don't run any traffic, right? Because
there's no traffic that feeds the
content. Technical ecosystem, you want
to create a lookike audience. You want
to create a custom audience or you want
to create an interestbased audience.
Interestbased is targeting
entrepreneurship, lead generation,
specific uh audiences. Whenever you're
selling towards the finance market,
let's say you're B2C ecom offer, you can
target interest within ecom fitness, you
can target interest within fitness.
Custom audience is making a custom
audience based on your Instagram
followers. So whenever your Instagram
followers are very very good quality,
you will be able to create a custom
audience around that, which is something
I'm going to show you in a bit. Now
lookalike audience is an audience that
looks like a custom audience. So you can
choose 1 to 10% based on how much you
want your audience to look like your
current audience. What is the difference
between boosting and business manager?
So the pros of business manager is that
it can be leveraged with a pixel has
more options to make it custom. Has the
ability to launch more adsets at the
same time. It's excellent for testing
for volume and tracking. This is great
for B toc for testing. The consequences
are based on data normally has been
proven to give a lower quality lead
flow. So complexity in the setup needs
more time. Right? When you optimize for
lower quality lead flow and it costs
more time to set it up, it's sometimes
energy draining, meaning you don't get
the highest return for your time
investment. Pros about boosting a post
is leverages existing organic content
that is already proven to resonate with
your audience. Quick, easy to set up,
can be done directly from IG. No lots of
work, slightly harder to track. What we
do with our clients is we set it up in
business manager. We test everything and
the winning campaign, we launch that on
Instagram directly. Now, what do you
need to do for this? Click on traffic
campaign. Then you click on next. You
don't change anything in the campaign
individually. The adset name you change
that to target social duration for
example entrepreneurship IG
180 days. You click on Instagram or
Facebook only. You click next. Now you
have to understand and write down your
reach. Understand that very well. The
destination and bit control. Don't fill
anything here. Keep that blank. You
focus on your Instagram profile not your
Facebook profile. You click on next. 60
budget. So this is 15 bucks USD. I would
recommend to keep it at least at 10
bucks if you want to create some slight
of profitability. If you don't even have
10 bucks a day to spend on ads, you
shouldn't be running ads. Makes no
sense. Next. After next, you click on
switch to original audience. I've spent
over $6 million with my clients included
on the profile funnel. We've spent over
almost $1 million around 8 to 900 right
now in the last four to five months with
all my clients on story ads. Switch to
original audience. Use original audience
and then you can create a new lookike
audience. So you target the exact
destination, the country which could be
either uh United States, United Kingdom,
Australia, Canada, Denmark, Netherlands,
Italy, depends on the country that
you're targeting obviously, right? You
fill that in search locations, you click
next. Then this is very important. You
can focus on broad no interest meaning
you for example say finance offer 20 to
45 in terms of age, demographic. Men add
demographics, interest or behaviors. You
don't do anything there. you just leave
it blank. When you focus on a niched
market with interest, you can focus on
entrepreneurship, you can focus on
social media marketing, you can focus on
content marketing like any of them. Or
when you decide to create a lookalike
audience, you click on everyone who
engage with this professional account.
You don't change anything to this. The
only thing that you're choosing is this
option. If you choose any other option
in the event types, it won't [__]
work. 180 days. If you do 30 days,
normally people don't have big enough
Instagram, so it won't attract or um
interact with enough reach. So you want
to do 180 days or 365 days. IG engagers
180 days. Create a new audience. Then
always target 3% equal to the audience
whenever you are in B2B. Whenever you
are in B TOC, do 7 to 10%. The reason
why is because as we said, you can focus
on a more broad market. It's not needed
to specifically focus on one market.
Now, what are the interests that you can
target? Because I have helped fitness
coaches scale to over $100,000 a month.
I have helped mindset coaches scale to
over $100,000 a month with an indirect
offer. We've helped finance offers in
the B2B, the BDC market. People that
help other people scale. We've helped
visible offers interest coaching. Let's
say you're in the digital marketing
space. Coaching, entrepreneurship,
digital marketing, online advertising
are the greatest creatives. When you're
in sales marketing or legion, let's say
you have a BC setting or sales offer,
Legion, sales, online advertising, and
social media marketing are great. Let's
say you're in a corpse like the firms I
have some clients that have corporations
like in real estate and things like
that. Carpentry, lawyer, realtor.com or
roofing contractor website. Very
important that you always, as I said,
and I described that here, always use
interest targeting. So when you see
fields of study, never use that. Always
use interest specifically. and health
and fitness, healthy lifestyle, Pilates,
vitamins and nutritions. Pilates works
very well because it's a hot topic in
the market. Loads and loads of market
demand for this market demand. Crazy.
Um, physical exercise, human
meditations, physical exercise, weight
training. I skilled my client Ibraim to
$200,000 a month with his uh hypnosis
offer. I skilled my client Andress with
his anxiety offer to over $50,000 a
month. This is excellent. Excellent
interest advantage turned off. So, when
you actually set up the adset, right,
with the operation, you click this off.
Don't don't click on this. Then you
click on manual campaigning. You only
focus on Instagram reels, Instagram
profile reels, and Instagram stories. If
you want to run profile ads or story
ads, don't choose anyone else. It will
[__] up your ad. Because the whole point
is you use these ads to optimize
conversion and to create interest to
your profile that has the content and
your stories do the exact same thing.
And that's very important to understand.
At analyzation, you can exactly see the
cost per um profile click, right? the
cost per profile visit as we can see
that's what we're going to track here as
well. These are the stats for B TOC and
these are the stats for B toc. I just
made this in a plane this whole board in
eight hours. I'm just obsessed with
business. I I'm so I love what I do.
It's it's great. Life makes itself so
much easier when you actually obsess
with what you do. When when you love
what you do and you truly enjoy what you
do, it makes life so much easier because
being obsessed with something leads
towards willing to create an outcome of
understanding no matter how you get
there. Now, as we see here, profile,
story, creative operation, add
Instagram, single video or photo.
Obviously, it's a video when it's a
profile ad. And then, obviously, it's a
picture when it's a story ad. Very
simple. Then, creative visit Instagram
profile tracking options. Put that all
off. No need for the profile funnel. We
can add uh I have a custom software that
I currently utilize that is extremely
optimized for conversion when it comes
down to tracking. So, it can manually
track as we see here, feedback
ecosystem, add analyzation, add
tracking. You can track the profile
funnel and the story ads in a couple
ways because right now you have the
question how to make adjustments to an
ad and when to do this with what
metrics. How to track see which ads are
performing well. That's probably a
question you have as well for me. Then
how do I track which followers came from
an ad? And the last question you have is
how do I decide a budget on scaling
these ads? You don't [__] know. You
have no clue. So you know the stats
here. The second question is for you to
answer for me to answer it to you is you
can track notifications. When you go to
followers on Instagram, you go to the
red area and you click here. You need to
have your business Instagram. You need
to have it set on business Instagram.
You need to have your Instagram updated.
And you need to be able to sell or to
run ads on a business ad account that is
integrated with your Instagram for you
to be viable to actually track this
marketing appointment setting sales. You
need to have a sheet to constantly do
this. This is all automated by the way.
So it you can automate this from
Instagram to automatically track it
within your sheet. The user database
KPIs KPI sales. If you want to know
exactly how your setup performs, how
your closer performs and how the the the
amount of users that you have collected,
their email, their phone number, their
name, everything like that. Um, second
thing that you could do, a client on
boarding form. This is so crucial. If
you don't have a client on boarding
form, I'm not sure what you do. You need
to have a form that makes statements
about the reason why clients joined
because this will give you an
understanding of why they joined. So,
I'll give you this example. When we
click on this link, you can see here,
this is what I sent to my clients. Very
excited you got on board to start with
us. What is your name? Then I'd love to
know what the first touch point is of
knowing me. Is that a referral? Did
someone came in from a referral? Was it
a YouTube video? Was it an Instagram ad?
Was it a real or was it any team member?
Maybe any other referral. Right? This is
so crucial to understand. You have to
understand that when you know this, you
can skill infinite because you can see
after six months of onboarding 20
clients what the 10 worst clients have
in common and the 10 right clients have
in common for you to attract more right
clients to create that cycle. Now when
you have that done, you obviously want
to use this business column as well. So
when you go to your business manager,
you go to your column, you click on
sales, you click on custom columns, and
you add the results step column. This
allows you to see the prova visits. And
when you hover over it like this with
your mouse, it will show this all
conversions, which then showcases the
350 followers that came from that
specific individual creative. And to
give you an indication of what you need
to do, if your ro is above 10x, increase
your spend by three. If your ro is above
4x, increase your spend by two. If
you're rorowaz on the profile funnel and
I know 3.4 3 to four is already high
compared to the VSSL funnel but let's
say it's three to four. You need other
components in a company you need to
understand that there are other
components in the company not working.
Your closer is [__] Your etc is [__]
Your conversion process isn't optimized.
Your content isn't good enough. This is
a lot a lot of the problems that my
clients struggle with um before they
came to me. A lot of clients say Nick
you know what I do the profile funnel.
It's working amazingly well. Or I do
VSSL ads but you know what my conversion
is like 3 to 4x. And that is a massive
problem because you can easily get it to
10x. But how does the actual creative
looks like, right? How do we optimize
for different types of story creatives
when we run the story funnel? We need
credibility driven creatives, a
lifestyle driven creatives and story ad
creatives. Meaning this is specifically
for B2B, B2B. This is specifically for
B2C depending on the interest that
you're targeting, right? And obviously
we have here our data archive. So we see
exactly what's working, what's not
working. On the top, we generate the
traffic within a 24-hour range. We put
up a story. We launch this story. We see
the profile interaction on our Instagram
and on our business manager. Then we all
lead that towards one specific link here
in bio that leads to my YouTube for
example. So I could showcase showcase
people the conversion. Again, you're
watching for [__] almost a half hour
right now. Like at this point I know you
can become a buyer at this point. You're
watching right now. I'll tell you right
now that I can guarantee that each
individual one of you that is watching
right now will become a buyer. Whether
it's in 5 years or two years or two
days, I don't know, but you will become
a buyer. You would never spend your
interest and time on watching me if you
don't think I have value to add. That's
how it works with everyone. And that's
the beauty about YouTube videos. You can
showcase I can showcase my in-depth
value on YouTube. That's why if you
don't have a YouTube channel and you're
in the fitness space or you're in the
bisop space or you have an info products
for highv value B2B achievers, you
you're stupid because how do you plan on
providing so much value as I do better
in only 3 minutes maximum on Instagram?
It's technically impossible. So that's
what you need. Ads, IG, YouTube, it
creates conversion in the bottom of the
funnel, the middle of the funnel, top of
the funnel, and that leads to audits or
it leads to qualified followers or
calendarly bookings instantly. So you
collect users and you have constantly
like you kind of with this system, the
three-step system, as I used the coffee
shop example in the beginning. You
eliminate inconsistency because what is
happening right now? You're at 10K a
month. Cool. One month you can still
theif you can scale the 50K a month.
Incredible. But what causes the drops in
the info space? Why are so many info
products dipping back to 30, scaling
back up to 100 and then again dipping
back to maybe even zero for a couple
months? That is because there's no
sustainability created in each
component. We have offer and that is the
marketing side of things, right? Then
obviously we have acquisition,
we have sales, so conversion and
fulfillment. Let's say right now you're
a one-man show. You are the person that
is responsible for all these components
in the company. So the first thing we
need to understand is that they're
connected to each other. Whenever your
setter books the most unqualified
appointments, your closer will never
close deals. And when your whole
front-end team isn't even here, you
would have nobody to fulfill for.
Meaning this all interconnects to one
system. And that system that is your
company. Now all these systems are
connected. Meaning it's a chain. It's a
cycle. Meaning if one of the components
isn't optimized for 100%, it will
instantly indicate a lack into the next
component that is only optimized for
80%. The next one for 70%. And in the
next one, the fulfillment sucks because
it's only optimized for 30%. What
happens when you have unqualified
clients or clients that have fear,
clients that don't get results? You as a
human instantly start to allocate your
time and your money towards making sure
that your clients are happy. But what if
you spend all your days, 8 hours a day
on fulfilling? Who is going to make sure
that the clients come in in the front
end? No one. Who does the acquisition
when you don't have a setter? No one.
Who closes the deals? No one. Because
you have no actual physical time and
mental space to be able to deliver for
this component. Meaning, the only
solution to this is you need to have a
lean team and automations. If you don't
have a system in place to create
predictability in what you're building,
you constantly encounter these dips
where you make a lot of money because
you're focused on making a lot of sales
and then you focus on a fulfillment. You
make almost no sales because you don't
have time for it. The front end needs to
look like a info business. The back end
needs to look like a agency, right?
Because you want to have systems and
integrations to be able to create
leverage. What is the whole point of
what we're doing as coaches and
consultants? It's to create leverage in
the systems that we're building. Our
value as founders is dictated by the
amount of leverage that we create. It's
nothing to do with the amount of hours
we work. When our consistent inputs are
happening constantly, no matter if it's
coming from me, my team member, my
closer, myself, it doesn't matter who
it's coming from. as at least if your
inputs are very consistent every single
time like I do on my story sequences
like I do on my short form content like
I have with my YouTube long form content
my client interviews and my client
retreats even my long form YouTube
videos then you have to understand that
it creates predictability in my system
so it's a continuous approach of
refinement I create new concepts every
single time that tend to do very very
well I create new concept in my YouTube
videos but only inputs is not enough you
need someone that can help You redefine
your marketing approach constantly
within your every single component
within your fulfillment, within your
marketing, within your sales because
whenever it stagnates, you don't grow to
the next level. I'm constantly
redefining new concepts. But the only
reason why I can do this is because I
have market data. I track [__] I know
what I'm doing. Whether it's in the ads,
whether it's here in the content,
whether it's in my technical analysis
with the story sequences, whether it's
within my fulfillment or offer, I know
what to do to create new concepts that
create scale. So, it's constantly
creating a new concept, gathering data
around it, analyzing it with your team,
monitoring it, adjustments for you to be
able to create more predictability. And
when you do this every single time, you
create predictability. We made 100K
month grow acquisition. As you can see,
we made 230K in July. We're already at
$75,000 cash for this month, which is
[__] incredible. It's so much money.
I'm 22 years old and I make $75 thou
technically $90,000 with the two crypto
payments in the past 4 days. That's
ridiculous. That is absolutely insane to
say. How is it possible? Like, do you
not get frustrated whenever you're
currently whenever you have your Bisob
offer, you have your BB offer right now.
Do you not get frustrated looking at
this? Like I would I'm [__]
frustrated when I look at some guys that
are 20 years old make don't make more
money than I I'm like I get so
frustrated about how that's possible and
I tend to solve I tend to educate myself
instantly about why that happens then I
tend to understand is there something
that I can change about this and then I
instantly take the action of changing it
adapting myself into creating
scalability in what I do right because
so many people are stuck within their
info product and I'll tell you this this
That's one of the biggest problems. So
many people that sell info are stuck.
You can't seem to make 10020, 200,
$300,000 a month. And that's the biggest
problem and that's the biggest worry
because info is one of the easiest
business models to make money with.
That's a fact. Older companies, they
make 70k, 130k, 80k, 240k, they drop
back to 20. It's the inconsistency that
matters, right? And the most important
thing is you want to have a lean team
with great people. Every single
department gets attention at the same
time. The founder oversees the company,
focuses on the high leveraged tasks,
which for me, for example, is making
this YouTube video. I'll definitely get
10 people paying me after this YouTube
video because what I'm explaining not
only logically makes sense but also
technically makes sense and also makes
sense from a social proof perspective
because you see my YouTube videos, you
go to my you go to my proof right now.
You see, okay, Nick actually has helped
a lot of people. Nick showcases his live
payment processor. So, you see that the
money I'm making is [__] real.
Meaning, this is the exact system I
utilize for my company. This is the
exact system that you can utilize for
your company. And that's exactly the
system that creates scale for all of our
companies. meaning we need to implement
it now the moment it's possible the
problems that you have are the ones that
I have solved that is your this is
exactly your desired outcome it's a
fully booked calendar with one closer
that closes on a 60 to 70% closing rate
with amazing people look at this 80%
qualified sorry 100% confident that's
why I'm booking this call I'm eager to
invest and I have multiple four figures
to invest same here you know you can see
I have multiple four figures to invest
as well here I have multiple four
figures to invest 100% confident I have
multiple four figures to invest. I just
know. I didn't even saw it. I just know
because all of the calls that we book in
our calendar are people with capital,
people with interest, people that
understand their own problems, people
that just need one last push to
understand the solution and see if that
fits their problem. Done. Look, you can
easily see here. Done. Life isn't
complex when you know how to run a
company and create consistency in it.
Listen guys, like it's just fun, you
know? Like I I just love business
because it's just a [__] fun game to
play. And I don't know things people
know that are making a million dollars a
month. You guys don't know things that I
know because you guys are making
anywhere between 10 to 100K per month,
maybe even nothing. Maybe you're
planning on starting your info product.
The two people we help very important is
people that have a very good skill. Like
one of my clients, Daniel, I scaled him
to $100,000 a month within his first
month. And the reason why that happens,
people al always ask me the reason why
this happens. And I see the biggest
change into people that scale fast that
start from zero are the people that are
massive experts in their already
existing skill in their field. Daniel
was running a 200k per month Airbnb
physical company in London in the UK.
Now he came to me said Nick I want to
build an info product. Boom. We did it.
We applied all the metrics, all the
systems, the integration, the
implementation and the information into
his company. He makes 100k a month in
the first month with 80% profit margin.
One closer, one setter. Now older people
already run an info product. They
already make decent money. They make
like 20 30k. Normally it's like in the
in the health space or finance space,
B2B or B TOC. They come to me and they
say, "Nick, you know what? Like I want
to solve the same problems." And the
most of the time these people, they
solve the [__] wrong problems. The
reason why you're not making money is
because you don't you cannot oversee the
problems you have from a drone
perspective accurately understanding the
ones you actually have and the ones you
don't have. You just want to be able to
scale a company, have fun, and have a
lean team. You know what? Like, we're
we're all done. Info isn't made to
[__] sell. Info isn't made to build
massive companies. Info isn't made to
build a team of 17,000 people, right?
You don't want to have a team of 100
people. Why would you? What's fun about
that? Build a software company, build an
ecom company. But info is made to make
high profit, high profitability, create
scale with amazing clients, and then
allocate that capital towards different
sources. So you have at least with your
info business an amazing flow of cash
flow. To showcase the clients that I
work with, as you can see, Daniel
teaching 95ers how to start an Airbnb
business. Warren makes 100K per month
selling high ticket coaching. Ibra makes
200K per month hypnotizing people.
Andreas make [__] 50K per month in
his first three months helping people
overcome anxiety. We have people with
finance offer business coaches scaling
from 19 to $76,000. People that do
similar stuff to what I do. It's
incredible. Info is one of the best
games to play and it's the right time to
play it right now for you to create
scale in the thing that you're doing and
that's exactly what makes you the most
amount of money. Boom. New reel popping
up. I [__] love this business game.
It's so fun. Look, a new followers
coming in every single minute because I
run one ad sequence. I run one ad. This
ad leads to my profile. This profile
leads towards reals, towards stories,
and towards YouTube videos that leads
towards boom, my calendar. Sorry, my
calendar. And that calendar leads
towards a closer and that closer leads
towards this boom. That that's what it
leads to. It's not that complicated. You
just need to make sure you implement it
the right way. You get it done and you
get somebody that understands this at
top level. So if you're ready to solve
your problems, booking a call right now.
If you don't have the capital, if you
don't have multiple four figures, at
least don't even book in a call. It
doesn't make any sense. I don't want to
waste your time. Please don't waste our
time. Like this is also the beauty,
right? I do pool marketing for the last
one and a half year and it has made my
life so much easier. Instead of put
doing push marketing and constantly
emotionally selling people, constantly
attracting the wrong clients, it it
makes business so complex. Whether you
have a B2B or B TOC offer, it doesn't
matter if you operate on volume or
quality. It matters on how you the type
of clients that you attract that will
make your life easier. Signing 20
clients at 5K so much easier.